blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
davidpackman Welcome to the David Pacman
show I Am David pakman if he dyed his
hair red and got stung by a thousand
bees
uh I am Jesse dollar Moore thanks for
joining me today again I want to thank
David for asking me to to co-host but uh
substitute this week it's uh I'm
flattered I'm honored and I would
appreciate it if you would follow me on
social media I'm at dollar more just
about everywhere from YouTube Twitter
Tick Tock I'm all over the place just at
dollar more today I want to talk about
friend of the program
Mike Lindell or as David would call him
Mike pillow
the Cyber Symposium that has been talked
about for seemingly ever started today
and it was postponed because of
he was hacked according to Mike Lindell
which obviously cannot be trusted
because he is a grifter and a charlatan
and a liar
I'm going to read from this article in
the independent briefly and then I'm
gonna play a couple clips from the
madness that ensued today
Mike pillow excuse me my pillow CEO Mike
Lindell delays start of cyber Symposium
claiming he has been hacked conspiracy
theorist claims there was more evidence
of election malfeasance in November and
December than any crime in history
that's saying a lot considering the the
crimes that we have witnessed throughout
history that Donald Trump lose in an
election was the biggest
it says a lot about not just where the
right is right now but also where Mike
Lindell is and before I go on I want to
admonish everybody that if you're listen
I'm a guy I don't mind a few insults I
don't mind flinging a few names here and
there but to impugn this man because he
is a former drug addict I think is
misguided I don't need to come to Mike's
defense like Mike like we're friends
but addiction is a disease addiction
isn't a moral failure and if you're
gonna pick on somebody for something
that shouldn't be it there's plenty of
ammunition to use against Mike Lindell
that doesn't involve
um his struggles with addiction
having said that I want to read a little
bit from this article my pillow CEO and
pro-trump conspiracy theorist Mike
Lindell delayed the start of his
quote-unquote cyber Symposium after
claiming that the whole technology was
attacked
I guess I could do the the Mike Lindell
voice for the quotes
um the whole technology was attacked
yeah because he is like a character from
the movie Fargo
we need to get the word out because they
blocked the thing
uh technologist
futurists understander of modernity and
uh technology they blocked the the thing
but this is part of what I'm going to
talk about today this is a cover-up this
is the absolute cover-up of the worst in
history Mr Lindell told a crowd in South
Dakota on Tuesday the audience had
gathered to hear evidence of for the
baseless conspiracy theory that the 2020
election was stolen from former
president Donald Trump Mr Lindell
claimed that his Symposium will show
that China hacked the election to make
sure that Joe Biden won there's no
evidence of this and election Security
Experts have said that the 2020 election
was one of the safest in U.S history now
I will remind you I'm sure you remember
that in November Donald Trump's own
Department of Homeland Security declared
this election the safest and most secure
in the history of the country
that's saying something
but still these conspiracy Ding Dongs
are running across the country hosting
cyber symposiums with their fake
nonsense their streaming data of just
merely metadata
and attempting to continue to whip the
right into a frenzy into a
conspiratorial rage that we already
witnessed violence at the hands of
these people who believe Donald Trump
lost are the same people who stormed the
capital
harming over 150 police officers
the same people
so this isn't just a fanciful thing of
some Wingnut out there in South Dakota
there are real world
ramifications to this real harm can be
done real lives can be ruined
here's a couple of video clips
the first is when he's announcing the
postponement the short postponement
because of the dreaded hack but we do
have a backup plan it still be probably
another five minutes
and um I want all of you guys or all you
guys to know that out there that this is
why because I need to get the word out
we can't even get the word out to the
people that are prankspeech.com because
they block the thing or blocked the
thing
um but this is part of what I'm going to
talk about today this is the cover-up
this is the absolute cover-up of this of
the worst crime in history
and we're going to talk about all this
today this is um and you're going to see
all kinds of things you're going to
educate everybody we're going to show
them the they uh we're going to be
running I'll show you over here you see
this data that's running there that's
cyber data from the from what I've got
let's see if it's moving
um yeah it's not it's not rotating yet
but there's they're going and end the
stream for days and we put Six States up
there
um
but I just we're not going to start the
regular program though because I want to
start because it's all educational and
it all goes in sequence I will say this
everybody tonight you're going to see
something at seven o'clock
that um it's going to change the world
um and um and then also tomorrow
[Applause]
you're gonna
that Applause seems a little tepid
[Laughter]
for the announcement to come on the
heels of the announcement that it's
going to change the world
it changed yeah change the world I'll
give you a little clap uh the other part
that I want to share with you is uh and
I'm laughing by the way because it is
hilarious this man is a funny person he
is objectively Goofy
um someone came to him and said oh we're
gonna go to lunch and he refused in fact
he he got aggressive about it and I'm
not taking a long time I'm gonna live
stream
just bizarre they attacked me they
buried it
you think about that
but they got something they want to show
you off stage here okay I guess we have
something off stage but so we're live
streaming though so you want to talk
well I think we're going to I think
we're set up for a break and maybe we're
going to talk a little bit right when we
get back there we're going to go into no
we're not going on a break put up that
movie again run the movie there's no
breaks we're streaming 72 hours live
streaming so around the world this never
stops you guys can go eat that's fine
but I ain't eating I'm staying up here
for 72 hours before they ruin our signal
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen lunch is now
available in the back hallway thank you
yeah we're gonna put the movie up again
if everybody missed it I want to go put
the movie Up ovulation system and then
when we come back from the movie we're
going to help Dr Frank Street or go he's
going to get on there and do his
presentation so is the movie going came
together because they are guys this is
the movie y'all heard about this morning
with this movie so no lunch for Lindell
he's too focused on the task at hand to
uncover the world changing data at his
cyber Symposium which by the way
uh is being live streamed by like Steve
Bannon on real America's voice you know
not fake America's voice real America's
voice
uh related to all of this election
misinformation disinformation propaganda
is this news that Dominion the voting
machine uh company is not only have they
sued uh Mike Lindell not only have they
sued Rudy Giuliani not only have they
sued Sidney Powell they are now suing
Newsmax oan and Patrick Byrne who is the
CEO of overstock.com
so someone who is fundamentally
committed to anti-democratic principles
Patrick Byrne owns a company out there
that you may or may not do business with
and you may or may not want to know or
have that information reading from The
Insider Dominion Sue's Newsmax oan and
Overstock CEO Patrick Byrne for
promoting election conspiracy theories
Dominion voting system sued Newsmax and
one America news network on Tuesday
accusing the far-right media
organizations of defamation for pushing
far-fetched conspiracy theories that the
election technology company rigged the
2020 presidential election
Republicans love
corporate autonomy Republicans love to
treat corporations like people so they
have to be on board with this lawsuit no
wouldn't you think Tuesday's lawsuit
against oan accused it of engaging quote
in a race to the bottom with Fox and
other outlets such as Newsmax to spread
false and manufactured stories about
election fraud end quote
Dominion quickly became the focus of
this downward spiral of Lies as each
broadcaster attempted to outdo the other
by making the lies more outrageous
spreading them further and endorsing
them as strongly as possible the lawsuit
said it added that although the lies
promoted by oan were quote verifiably
false they were still devastating to
Dominion's reputation
and this
on its face seems logical it seems
reasonable it seems like common sense
that their reputation would be impugned
and their bottom line affected by this
they have to show damages
because before the 2016 election
could you have named
a voting a company that ran voting
machines
I could not
and it is because of that publicity is
because of that coverage is because of
these pernicious and Sinister conspiracy
theories that we do know their name
this lawsuit does seem to have Merit
Dominion also accused oan host Chanel
rheon not her real name and Christina
Bob of amplifying and spreading false
claims about Dominion the network
deputized Rihanna as an in-house
spokesperson for all Dominion related
content the lawsuit said Dominion began
in January by suing Sydney Powell as I
mentioned Rudy Giuliani who claimed
Dominion has secret ties to the regime
of now dead Venezuelan dictator Hugo
Chavez and developed technology that
flipped votes from then president Donald
Trump to now President Joe Biden
Dominion as an aside here also sued my
pillow CEO Mike Lindell who pushed
versions of that falsehood
so Mike pillow and all of this these
this cohort of of dum-dums
and uh purveyors of conspiracy theories
they're all in the same camp and they're
all doing damage to the Republic these
are these are fake dreads they claim to
love the country they claim to cherish
our freedoms they they they rattle on
about the Constitution of the United
States and having taken an oath many of
them and they violate that oath
they violate the the the possibility
that they have respect for Democratic
rule when they are actively months after
a free and fair election months after
they are continuing to spread gossip and
misinformation whipping their their
followers their adherence into a frenzy
such that they attack the government
such that there's a violent Insurrection
at the United States capital where
people died
where they like I said yesterday erect a
hangman's Gallow chanting hang Mike
Pence
stalking throughout the capitol grounds
Nancy Pelosi where are you
ominous dangerous un-American
anti-democratic
and where is their leader to quell this
where is Donald Trump who's certainly
not uh short for words he's not short on
media appearances he could end this
just like he could have ended the
pandemic early on
instead he so doubt about masks
Donald Trump could go on Fox he could
make the rounds to these idiot networks
he could go on Fox News he could go on
Newsmax he could go on one America news
and say
stop it everybody we need to come
together
Insurrection and violent revolt against
your government isn't the way forward we
will beat them at The Ballot Box next
time but you know what Donald Trump
doesn't have the metal Donald Trump
doesn't have it in himself to do the
right thing because the right thing
would mean taking a step back from the
spotlight
the right thing would mean not
making it all about Donald Trump
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist then what they do is take
thousands of popular non-fiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for if there's a full book you're
thinking about buying you can use
blinkist to get a sample first just
think how much you can enrich Yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes I
recently read A Brief History of Time Of
course by the great Stephen Hawking this
is a book that I have been aware of for
so long and other things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories stories
and a subscription is only about eight
bucks a month and you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
davidpackman I've put the link right
underneath this video I did a story
yesterday where I talked about the
differences between Republicans and
Democrats especially related to holding
our own accountable
and in that video uh I discussed Andrew
Cuomo and that there was an unavoidable
March toward impeachment that wasn't uh
going to be able to be uh
avoided
unavoidable he couldn't avoid it
that's how it works that's how language
works
dumb guy so uh this morning
Press Conference was held just about 9
30 my time here in Southern California
and
Andrew Cuomo I almost called him Chris
again dumb guy
uh Andrew Cuomo resigned or he gave us
two weeks notice
and there are a few moments in his press
conference in his announcement video his
live stream that I want to address
because yes he's doing the right thing
he's leaving he is doing it to save
himself the shame of being the only
governor of the state of New York to
ever be impeached and removed from
office
but he is doing it in a very
recalcitrant way
it's aggressive it is trying to give
deference to the 11 women who have
accused him of misconduct while also
saying
I didn't know I the rules have changed
I'm an affectionate guy
and I don't believe that is acceptable
it certainly in a post metoo era
but it's not acceptable for a leader
for a politician for someone who is in
in charge of policy decisions especially
related to sexual assault and sexual
misconduct and he is a man who should be
intelligent enough to understand consent
you don't get to just kiss people
without them saying it's okay to touch
me it's okay to put your body on mine
let's cut to this first clip where he's
talking about this thing that he just
didn't know I take full responsibility
for my actions
I have been
too familiar with people
my sense of humor can be insensitive and
off-putting
I do hug and kiss people casually
women and men
I have done it all my life
it's who I've been since I can remember
in my mind
I've never crossed the line with anyone
but
I didn't realize the extent to which the
line has been redrawn
there are generational and cultural
shifts that I just didn't fully
appreciate so Andrew Cuomo would take on
the old grandpa approach to his defense
here I'm an old man and I didn't know
that the rules have changed calling
ladies honey and sweetie kissing him on
the cheeks
this doesn't pass the smell test for me
anyway
I think in many ways Andrew Cuomo has
been
um a standout governor
I think he got a little too much praise
for his coveted response especially in
the wake of Scandal where they lied
about nursing home deaths
as a as a mechanism to Stave off an
investigation that's the that's the
excuse they gave that's not what I'm
saying they said that
but this is not an acceptable excuse
that I kiss a lot of people I hug a lot
of people that's just me
listen I'm an affectionate guy I'm a
hugger I'm a toucher
but it is common sense that you don't
impose yourself upon someone else before
getting consent being told it's okay
it it just that's the way it is and
especially if you're the governor of the
state of New York knowing the immense
power and and influence and Authority
that you have in that position you have
to walk a little bit more carefully
because of that power the aura of
authority around you
you're not Joe who works down at the
Jiffy Lube who gets a little fresh with
the client
and doesn't know it because he's Joe who
works down at the Jiffy Lube you're the
governor of the state of New York
next up is again while he apologizes
and says oh I just didn't know he's
couching he's hedging his his apology
and and his uh admitting to what he did
with this is a political Witch Hunt it
all smacks very much to me uh like a
trump excuse now
you know me
I'm a New Yorker born and bred I am a
fighter
and my instinct is to fight through this
controversy because I truly believe it
is politically motivated
I believe it is unfair and it is
untruthful
and I believe it it demonizes behavior
that is unsustainable for society
if I could communicate the facts through
the frenzy
New Yorkers would understand I believe
that
but when I took my oath as governor
then it changed
I became a fighter but I became a
fighter for you
and it is your best interest that I must
serve
those are all words that have crossed
the lips of Donald Trump many times how
unfair it is that it's politically
motivated which is just another way to
say it's a Witch Hunt
that uh that that it's untruthful these
are lies
if they are lies Governor Cuomo then why
indeed sir are you resigning
if this is baseless why are you
resigning
you can't have it both ways that it's a
political Witch Hunt but then also admit
that a lot of women were offended
that they were uncomfortable they were
made uncomfortable by you and your
advances
not to mention the fact that some of
these accusations rise to the level of
criminal prosecution
reaching under women's blouses and
touching their breasts
running your finger along the belly
button
over to the side of the hip where the
weapon is carried on your female
protective duty state trooper
this isn't just I didn't know I'm a
Huggy guy
no
and then finally
uh the moment where he says he's going
to resign and I think that given the
circumstances
the best way I can help now
is if I step aside and let government
get back to governing
and therefore that's what I'll do
because I work for you
and doing the right thing
is doing the right thing for you
because as we say it's not about me it's
about we and in the wake of this the
female lieutenant governor of the state
of New York will be sworn in in about
two weeks or so to be the first female
governor of the state of New York
I find myself saying this a lot but it's
2021. we are on the heels of 2022 and
this is the first female governor in the
history of the state of New York
we can do better than that we can
absolutely do better than that and
listen I know I ruffle a lot of feathers
over on my own channel uh when I when I
wield criticisms of Democrats when I
have things to say that are critical of
Joe Biden or Nancy Pelosi or in this
case Andrew Cuomo
reasonable reasonable people can
disagree
agreeably and reasonably
and this might be one of those cases
a lot has been made a lot has been said
a lot has been suggested about the
sentences that are coming down and being
handed down or the manner with which the
January 6 insurrectionists are being
treated in federal jail there is no
federal bail system
um like there is in state courts or
local municipalities it's either your
your released on your own recognizance
or you're put on a house arrest with an
ankle monitor or your remanded to
custody until trial
and a federal judge this is a political
headline judge suggests feds are too
lenient toward January 6 defendants the
chief judge of the federal court in
Washington raised questions about why
pleading guilty to a misdemeanor was
permitted to resolve certain cases
now many of you don't know who I am but
I happen to have a close connection to
the January 6 Insurrection my wife and
uh co-host of my podcast I doubt it one
of them
this Dingus was my wife's High School
boyfriend I just I just got him away I
just got in the Capitol Building I was
the first one I hopped down into the
chamber and I was the first one to sit
and Nancy Pelosi that [ __ ]
she's a traitor she's treasonous save
the condolences
this was a long time ago it's not like
she escaped some culty relationship they
were kids
but this is the kind of of of people
that I was surrounded by growing up in
Idaho
Josiah cult who also related to this
story is being allowed all kinds of uh
plea deals for his promises to turn
States uh evidence and and testify
against his uh conspirators
there are absolutely deals being made
and I think this judge
has uh an important perspective a
federal judge suggested Monday that
Federal prosecutors would were being too
lenient in their handling of cases
stemming from the storming of the United
States capital as lawmakers were
convening on January 6 to certify Joe
Biden's victory in the presidential race
Barrel Howell the chief judge of the
federal court in Washington Deluge with
more than 550 prosecutions from the
capital Riot raised questions about why
some defendants were being permitted to
resolve their criminal cases by pleading
guilty to a misdemeanor and why the
amount of money prosecutors are seeking
to recover through those plea deals was
based on a relatively paltry estimate of
about 1.5 million in damages caused by
the rioters
Howell aired her doubts during what was
expected to be a routine morning hearing
to take the guilty plea of a capital
Riot defendant Glenn Croy of Colorado
Springs Colorado Croy was arrested in
February on charges that he and another
man Terry Lindsey illegally entered the
Capitol building on January 6th final
paragraph here under a deal with
prosecutors Croy was seeking to plead
guilty to a single misdemeanor charge of
parading or picketing in the capital
that carries a maximum sentence of six
months in jail and a fine of up to five
thousand
to overuse a term again this does not
pass the smell test they weren't just
their picketing it wasn't a protest they
weren't holding a parade
the intent of everyone there who entered
the capital was to disrupt the counting
of votes the certification of the 2020
presidential election
to overturn those results
to strike and Stoke fear in a
terroristic manner into the hearts and
minds of of legislators tasked with
constitutionally tasked with
certifying the vote
electing in a peaceful transfer of power
the next president of the United States
so I'm with
Beryl Howell I agree hard questions need
to be asked as we delve into these
particular prosecutions they shouldn't
prosecutors should not be too too quick
to allow plea deals
that will lighten the results and the
consequences for these insurrectionists
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
the Coronavirus
and the onslaught that has been foisted
upon the American people and indeed the
world has really laid bare
some very Sinister aspects of the
Republican Party
that they have completely jettisoned any
concern for the American people and the
Health and Welfare
of them
even their constituents this
beating the drum of self-reliance and
pulling yourself up by your bootstraps
and personal responsibility while
romantic to Republicans
doesn't play when we're talking about an
invisible virus
that can spread without anybody knowing
it
so it's not like a helmet law when you
ride a motorcycle that if you crack your
head open and spill your brains onto the
Interstate you're only hurting yourself
they can't make that argument Ein Rand
nonsense only goes so far but when you
try to practically apply those ideals to
a pandemic they fail
let's talk about Ted Cruz in an
appearance he made on Fox news on
Hannity's show really extolling the
virtues of no mandates for anything
watch this remarkable BS in a time of
Crisis people's characters revealed and
and the character of Democrats whether
it is Joe Biden whether it is Andrew
Cuomo whether it is Bill de Blasio
whether it is if you have a Newsome the
character from their perspective that
they do not respect your Liberty they do
not respect your right to make your
choices about your health care about
your children about your lives My Views
were very simple there should be no
mandates zero concerning covid that
means no mask mandates regardless of
your vaccination status that means no
man no vaccine mandates that means no
vaccine passports and I've introduced
legislation a build-a-band vaccine
passports this week I'm introducing a
bill to ban vaccine mandates and this
will I'm a week I'm introducing a bill
to end mask mandates now that doesn't
mean as the media likes to characterize
that I'm opposed to vaccines I actually
think vaccines are terrific I've taken
the vaccine my family's taking the
vaccine but I believe an individual
Choice individual responsibility you can
make the choice for your family these
mandates are coming and and as you noted
a few minutes ago talking about Dr fauci
what they're talking about is political
it's not tied to the science it is
political now
Ted Cruz because of you
because of your
colleagues your Republican goofball
colleagues who have made this political
and it is remarkable to me Senator Cruz
that you list all of these people that
you act like are are not concerned about
Americans Liberty or lives or or health
or welfare or well-being and it's all
Democrats
you named no one on your side the bomb
throwers the Jim Jordans
the the the the
holly from Missouri
the encouragers of insurrectionist you
didn't name anybody there
but to to poo poo mandates mask mandates
that absolutely curb the transmission of
the virus without a doubt fact
to to in one breath talk about that you
got the vaccine and it's it's safe and
it's good but also say but no one should
be forced to get it
the reason we're in a position to even
talk about having to mandate vaccines is
because you have vilified
and demonized the getting of the vaccine
so much so that there are millions of
Americans many of whom are in a very
very peculiar area of the country where
this kind of recalcitrance is common in
the south
and you've you've ginned up fear
all couched in personal responsibility
all all couched in uh Liberty
it is nonsense
and it is nonsense because if you go to
the grocery store and you've refused to
get the vaccine and you're asymptomatic
for the Coronavirus
and you pass it on to someone who is who
is immunocompromised
and unable for valid medical reasons to
get the vaccine and you give them covet
and they die
your rights
do not exceed do not extend beyond where
you can swing your arm have you heard
that before Ted Cruz
this is dangerous this is disgusting and
this is political that's all this is
from Ted Cruz
another one
of these vaccine
mandate near do Wells
is Rand Paul
from Kentucky
ostensibly a man of medicine an
ophthalmologist although not board
certified he created his own licensing
organization to license himself
these people he took to a video to
explain in a very aggressive manner how
he will not be bossed around you're not
the boss of me Nancy Pelosi watch this
it's time for us to resist they can't
arrest all of us they can't keep all of
your kids home from school it starts off
in Grand fashion they can't kill all of
us they can't arrest all of us
they can't persecute all of us
this is what this is boiled down to for
these types
Rand Paul who is absolutely uh
eradicated any credibility he once had
if he had any at all he has become an
absolute Trump Lackey a a trump
automaton he's a a facsimile
of Donald Trump
especially related to this particular
topic we will unfortunately let him
continue they can't keep every
government building closed
there's a few I would like to close too
closed or might ought to keep closed
we don't have to accept the mandates
lockdowns and harmful policies of the
petty tyrants and bureaucrats we can
simply say no heavy tyrants and
bureaucrats Petty tyrants
to Rand Paul and many who follow him
they believe that a that a that a public
health measure to keep children and the
the infirmed people who are especially
vulnerable to infection that keeping
them safe and healthy is tyranny
I would love to see a Rand Paul
put back in time
travel across the eons to to a time when
there were uh revolutionary machinations
in in the colonies
and see how he would have stood up
they there's a lot of talk about our
founding fathers risked their treasure
and their reputations and their sacred
honor to enter into the revolution to
free us and make us independent from
Great Britain
is this does he have the medal for that
I say no
Nancy Pelosi you will not arrest or stop
me or anyone on my staff from doing our
jobs
we have either had coveted had the
vaccine or been offered the vaccine we
will make our own health choices we will
not show you a passport we will not wear
a mask we will not be forced into random
screenings and testings so you can all
this means is we will not care for our
fellow Americans we will not be
concerned with the health and well-being
of our neighbors we don't care about
that
we're too busy owning the libs
I dare say uh Rand Paul's neighbor did
not go far enough continue your drunk
with power Reign Over the capitol
President Biden we will not accept your
agency's mandates or your reported moves
towards a lockdown no one should follow
the cdc's anti-science mask mandates and
if you want to shut down federal
agencies again some of which aren't even
back to work yet I will stop every Bill
coming through the Senate with an
amendment to cut their funding if they
don't come back to work in person
because this is pattern in practice for
Rand Paul
I'm gonna I'm gonna gum up the works
because that's all I'm good at I'm gonna
vote against this I'm gonna vote against
amendments I'm gonna offer amendments
that have no chance of passage in order
that I slow down the mechanism of the
Senate to slow any progress that might
be made in the course of uh signing
legislation into law by the president
unbelievable the temerity of this man
bureaucrats and union bosses we will not
allow you to do more harm to our
children again this year children are
not at any more risks from covid than
they are from the seasonal flu
with this
Dr Drew over here
we are witnessing a a massive spike in
infections of children of
hospitalization of children
and he stands here purporting to care
about kids while doing everything in his
power
to ensure that those spikes only
increase that we see more death more
destruction more Mayhem at the hands of
the virus getting a little assist from
Republican politicians everywhere every
adult who works in schools has either
had the vaccine or had their chance to
get vaccinated there is no reason for
Mass mandates part-time schools or any
lockdown measures children are falling
behind in school and are being harmed
physically and psychologically by the
tactics that you have used to keep them
from the classroom during the last year
we won't allow it again if a school
system attempts to keep children from
full-time in-person school I will hold
up every bill with two amendments one to
defund them and another to allow parents
the choice of where the money goes for
their child's education do I sound fed
up to you that's because I am I'm not a
career politician
foreign
Paul you can do better than that brother
I'm not a career politician since when
guy you've been in the Senate a long
time you've been in government a long
time I don't see you stepping away to go
work on eyes anytime soon you're
absolutely a career politician who again
your only move your go-to is to threaten
to gum up the works to threaten
obstructionism that's all you got
you're a reactionary ghoul watching
millions of Americans get the virus
hundreds of thousands of them die we
don't know where the ceiling of death is
in this country
and the reason we don't know the reason
we cannot estimate is because of
monsters like you
ghouls
like you
if you value what we do at the David
Pacman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show welcome
back to the David Pacman show I am Jesse
dollamore out of work stunt double for
Jim Gaffigan
So Yesterday something happened that
we've been waiting for for many years
and that is an infrastructure built to
pass during the Trump Administration it
seemed like infrastructure week was
every week
in perpetuity
materializing to nothing
and we passed less than we wanted less
than we need
certainly less than we deserve but
better than nothing
reading from this New York Times article
entitled Senate passes one trillion
dollar infrastructure Bill and even
Biden a bipartisan win the approval came
after months of negotiations and despite
deficit concerns reflecting an appetite
in both parties for a long-awaited
spending package
so the vote ended up being 69 to 30
which is telling that they were able to
get uh nearly 20 Republicans on board
even Mitch McConnell in fact
the Senate gave overwhelming bipartisan
approval on Tuesday to a one trillion
dollar infrastructure Bill to rebuild
the nation's deteriorating roads and
bridges and fund new climate resilience
and Broadband initiatives delivering a
key component of President Biden's
agenda the vote 69-30 was uncommonly
bipartisan the yes votes included
Senator Mitch McConnell of Kentucky the
Republican leader and 18 others from his
party who Shrugged off increasingly
shrill efforts by former president
Donald J Trump
to derail it
is the last part of that sentence
because that is it was indeed
the uh the the mo has been the mo of
trump and the Republicans for a long
time
I am still weary of what is happening
wary excuse me of what's Happening Here
what is to take place what's the uh what
Machiavellian motivations do they have
for overwhelmingly or for Republicans
it's overwhelming support of this bill
the historic investment in
infrastructure is what I believe you the
American people want what you've been
asking for for a long long time Mr Biden
said from the White House as he thanked
Republicans for showing a lot of courage
because in today's day and age
it is courage
to support an infrastructure bill that
is desperately needed as our bridges and
our tunnels and our roadways and our
infrastructure is literally crumbling
Mr McConnell who publicly declared that
his priority was stopping the Biden
agenda said in a statement that quote I
was proud to support today's historic
bipartisan infrastructure deal and prove
that both sides of the political aisle
can still come together around Common
Sense Solutions
if it were coming from anybody other
than Mitch McConnell I might believe it
the measure faces a potentially Rocky
and time-consuming path in the house
where speaker Nancy Pelosi and a
majority of the nearly 100 member
Progressive caucus had said they will
not vote on it unless the Senate passes
a separate even more ambitious 3.5
trillion dollar social policy bill this
fall that could put the infrastructure
bill on hold for weeks if not months and
the the the method by which they intend
to press the Senate to pass that 3.5
trillion dollar
appropriation is through reconciliation
where they won't need they could bypass
the filibuster they could bypass
Republican obstructionism
here is a little larger context a little
longer context of what Joe Biden said in
his speech first of all
I want to thank a group of senators
Democrats and Republicans
for doing what they told me they would
do
the death of this legislation was mildly
premature as reported
they said they're willing to work in a
bipartisan manner
and I want to thank them for keeping
their word it's just what they did
after years and years of infrastructure
week we're in the cusp of an
infrastructure decade
that I truly believe will transform
America so it was a good day for the
country certainly a good day from an
agendas agenda standpoint for President
Biden
there was another side though
that is the side of Mike Lee Republican
from uh Utah he is Ted Cruz without a
beard
not quite as salacious he's a little bit
more milk toast
but certainly an obstructionist
certainly someone who is whose agenda is
marked by his ability to not vote for
things that's his that's his uh his
Pride and Glory
is his ability to not vote here's Mike
Lee people are still digesting it
members of the Senate are still
digesting it
look
we're in a period of great inflation
brought on by a period of almost
unfettered unrestrained federal spending
it Bears no connection it seems to the
laws of mathematics or to the amount of
money that were brought in
this bill would spend a staggering 1.2
trillion dollars it would be yet another
inflation bomb in an economy that's
already been carpet bombed by other
inflation bombs I I grasp the fact that
it's difficult to put together a
bipartisan package I have nothing but
respect for each of our colleagues who
were part of this effort I also am
willing to acknowledge that the bill
does a lot of good things and would help
a lot of deserving beneficiaries there
are a lot of people who would benefit in
a lot of ways from it but there is a
huge problem with it it is not paid for
the reason that we know that that's a
problem that it's not paid for is that
the one consistent refrain that you hear
from its sponsors other than the fact
that it's bipartisan which which we know
in which we respect is the fact that
it's paid for
they'll say over and over again that
this bill is paid for but when you look
at the pays the pay Force they don't add
up
when you have pay force that don't
actually pay you're just going to add to
the debt and deficit and this isn't a
good time to be doing that it never
ceases to amaze me and never will cease
to amaze me these Republicans who
who Pride themselves now on on how is
this going to be paid for how are we
ever going to pay for this we're
subtling our children with debt
as though this is a household and debt
means the same thing as you owning a car
and having credit card debt it is not
the same thing
but two where was Mike Lee during the
Donald Trump Administration that was
running up one and one and a half
trillion dollar deficits while things
were good economically in the country
where were you Mike Lee
where were you
it just Rings Hollow now listen I would
uh I would be lying if I didn't say that
I'm a little nervous about the
aggressiveness of the progressives in
Congress the squad who I am
almost universally a fan of
but if if they push this too far and we
get nothing and they give the
Republicans an excuse
to back out and and not vote for for
whatever conference agreement they come
to on a bill
then we've lost
then we get nothing we don't even get
the one or 1.2 trillion
we get zero and we're back to square one
with the
um
infrastructure week week after week kind
of a situation it's not good
something I talk about a lot on my
channel is the existential threat that
white supremacists
play in America the threat that they
pose
Tucker Carlson being Chief among them I
rather famously if I was famous
I call him a lot of little cute names
little pet names
and I really do believe he is a a
googly-eyed feather duster he is a
haircut he is a trust fund goon he is a
soft-skinned smooth brained clown but he
also holds a position within the
American Zeitgeist that is is uh
undeniable
he hosts the the most popular cable news
show in all of cable news history
the most popular show on Fox News Right
Now by far and they're most popular ever
Hannity's ratings don't hold a candle to
Tucker Carlson's Bill O'Reilly in his
Heyday nowhere near Tucker Carlson's and
they keep him around even though he is
just draining on their budgets because
who advertises for Tucker Carlson no
Blue Chip companies up until a few weeks
ago it was just the my pillow guy and a
few others
but Tucker Carlson is advancing he has
tossed away the dog whistle and he is
advancing The Conspiracy Theory the
racist conspiracy theory of the great
replacement theory of white genocide
which used to be
talked about only in literal white
supremacist circles like at Neo-Nazi
camps and uh
Aryan Nation up in northern Idaho on my
home state
and he has taken it to prime time he has
taken it to the morning shows which is
what I want to talk about today he went
on Fox News
fox fox and friends you know the friends
over at Fox and Friends
and was extolling the virtues of the
great replacement Theory and believes in
a conspiratorial fashion that Joe Biden
is trying to destroy these are his words
destroy the country
by changing the demographics of America
watch this yeah I mean this you know
what this tells you honestly that what's
happening at the border is not a crisis
a crisis is a flood in Bangladesh it's
an act of God this is an intentional act
this is the administration bringing
felons violent criminals into our
country on purpose why would you do
something like that only to destroy it I
mean there's there's no other
explanation for this it's not an act of
compassion it's an act of hostility
against the United States in order to
change it forever I think this is the
greatest Scandal of my lifetime what's
happening on the border right now well
absolutely although you've heard
secretary mayorkas Tucker says the
strategy is working which makes you
wonder what is the strategy right well
the strategy is to change the
demographics of the country now when you
say that they have a heart attack and
they call you names but they say it out
loud I mean they say it on the floor of
the Senate dick Durbin did two weeks ago
this country is changing in a way that
benefits the Democratic party more
democratic voters there's no other
upside in this policy by the way it
doesn't help the people coming from
around the world there's a humanitarian
disaster unfolding thanks to the bite
Administration the only beneficiaries to
the people who run the Democratic party
and this is an effort to change the
country and we should be honest about it
and not be bullied into silence as they
take our country away and import violent
criminals what there is a lot there
there's a lot there to be sure
uh not only are is Joe Biden and this
Administration purposefully
trying to destroy the country
this is the greatest scandal in his
lifetime
these Republicans are using a lot of
this hyperbolic language surrounding Joe
Biden that it's the worst of this the
greatest crime this is the the greatest
Scandal of all the scandals of America
in the course of Tucker's 50 years on
the planet there are many this isn't
even a scandal but in order to whip his
audience into a frenzy and the the the
the larger Fox News audience since he's
on Fox and Friends
he has to use this kind of language
but to Rattle on about changing
demographics it really does put
everything in perspective during Donald
Trump's campaign there was a lot of
analysis around make America great again
the campaign slogan
and the question was asked for when when
was this moment that they hearken back
to and it's it it's certainly pre-1950
when schools and American life was
segregated
they oh they Pine for these these these
nuggets of History this is when they
believed America was great
when white dominance in this country was
absolutely unchecked and that is the
time for which Tucker Carlson yearns he
watched that again and the fact that the
country's demographics are naturally
changing when you're a beacon of light
and a Beacon of Hope to the world as the
Republicans have have yammered on about
for years
that's what you get people come here for
a better situation a better life for
themselves
and their posterity
but that scares Tucker Carlson
and he is intending to scare uh an
audience filled with people
who also yearn for those times
interesting though that he he has a CR a
critique about the word crisis and then
at the very end there this is a
humanitarian
disaster he wanted so badly to say
crisis but he couldn't because he just
poo pooed the word
and then of course the the refrain about
taking our country away
whose country Tucker
is it not also my country
is it not also people of color their
country
it this is no longer
safely a white country
the the the Melting Pot meme has really
been overused
but it is because it is what we are we
are a diverse country
diverse culturally
diverse ethnically diverse racially
diverse ideologically
and there are certain ideas that are no
longer welcome
white supremacy being among them Tucker
Carlson
maybe it is you who is trying to take
away our country
thank you
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors blinkist is the
app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an entire non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes you can try it for
free and get 25 off a subscription by
going to blinkist.com davidpackman